[Music]
what if electricity could travel forever
without being diminished what if a
computer could run exponentially faster
with perfect accuracy what technology
could those abilities build we may be
able to find out thanks to the work of
the three scientists who won the Nobel
Prize in Physics in 2016
David Thewlis Duncan Haldane and Michael
Koster le'ts won the award for
discovering that even microscopic matter
at the smallest scale can exhibit
macroscopic properties and phases that
are topological but what does that mean
first of all topology is a branch of
mathematics that focuses on fundamental
properties of objects topological
properties don't change when an object
is gradually stretched or bent the
object has to be torn or attached in new
places a donut and a coffee cup look the
same to a topologist because they both
have one hole you could reshape a donut
into a coffee cup and it would still
have just one that topological property
is stable on the other hand a pretzel
has three holes there are no smooth
incremental changes that will turn a
donut into a pretzel
you'd have to tear two new holes
for a long time it wasn't clear whether
topology was useful for describing the
behaviors of subatomic particles
that's because particles like electrons
and photons are subject to the strange
laws of quantum physics which involve a
great deal of uncertainty that we don't
see at the scale of coffee cups
but the Nobel laureates discovered that
topological properties do exist at the
quantum level and that discovery may
revolutionize materials science
electronic engineering and computer
science that's because these properties
lend surprising stability and remarkable
characteristics to some exotic phases of
matter in the delicate quantum world
one example is called a topological
insulator imagine a film of electrons if
a strong enough magnetic field passes
through them each electron will start
travelling in a circle which is called a
closed orbit because the electrons are
stuck in these loops they're not
conducting electricity but at the edge
of the material the orbits become open
connected and they all point in the same
direction so electrons can jump from one
orbit to the next and travel all the way
around the edge this means that the
material conducts electricity around the
edge but not in the middle here's where
topology comes in this conductivity
isn't affected by small changes in the
material like impurities or
imperfections that's just like how the
hole in the coffee cup isn't changed by
stretching it out the edge of such a
topological insulator has perfect
electron transport no electrons travel
backward no energy is lost as heat and
the number of conducting pathways can
even be controlled the electronics of
the future could be built to use this
perfectly efficient electron highway
topological properties of subatomic
particles could also transform quantum
computing quantum computers take
advantage of the fact that subatomic
particles can be in different states at
the same time to store information in
something called qubits these qubits can
solve problems exponentially faster than
classical digital computers the problem
is that this data is so delicate that
interaction with the environment can
destroy it but in some exotic
topological phases the subatomic
particles can become protected in other
words the qubits formed by them can't be
changed by small or local disturbances
these topological qubits would be more
stable leading to more accurate
computation and a better quantum
computer
topology was originally studied as a
branch of purely abstract mathematics
thanks to the pioneering work of thalis
Haldane and Koster let's we now know it
can be used to understand the riddles of
nature and to revolutionize the future
of technologies check out this playlist
for mind-bending videos about math and
physics and thanks for your support
you